[Music]
on this Tuesday night liberal staff
grilled about foreign meddling
allegations their testimony about what
they knew and when can't confirmed that
a briefing did uh take place
round two in the race for the White
House I'm running for re-election
confidence and concern about Joe Biden's
bid for a second term
[Music]
and making lifelong memories three
children see the world before they
slowly lose their eyesight forever
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Chris gayles good
evening and thanks very much for joining
us new developments tonight around a
thesis briefing given to Liberal
officials during the 2019 election
campaign top liberal and conservative
campaign directors appeared before a
Commons committee investigating
allegations of foreign election
interference pressure on prime minister
Justin Trudeau and his government has
steadily ramped up following allegations
China tried to influence the outcome of
the past two Federal elections and today
opposition MPS drilled down Mackenzie
gray is following the details for us
Mackenzie what stood out to you
well Chris it's the first time we've
heard from senior Liberal Party Staff
about what they knew of allegations of
electoral interference welcome to
procedure and house to Fierce the key
question from opposition MPS what
happened during his thesis brief in
giving to top Liberal Party officials
during the 2019 election who were the
senior Liberal Party officials who were
part of this briefing I'm not in a
position where I can discuss the
contents and briefings that were
provided to the liberal party we can't
confirm that a briefing did uh take
place while the 2019 liberal campaign
director wouldn't share what ceases told
him Global News has previously reported
ceases discussed then candidate for Don
Valley North Han dong and his ties to
Beijing with Liberal Party officials
during the briefing according to
National Security sources Jeremy
broadhurst did not confirm that the
briefing concerned Hong dong and
described it as an information only
conversation dong now the independent MP
for the writing has denied the
allegations and previously said csis has
never spoke I've never received a phone
call from Jesus I've never made aware
that if there is investigation whether
by ceases rsmp or elections Canada
pertain to my nomination or my election
that sees his briefing happen on
September 28 2019 and the liberal
campaign director who was in the meeting
told the Prime Minister about it soon
after I briefed him
um in a safe manner on the 29th
Justin Trudeau has been asked numerous
times about the thesis briefing and
other allegations about Dong but he has
never confirmed he knew the contents of
what ceases told Liberal Party officials
it is not up
to unelected
security officials to dictate to
political parties who can or cannot run
members of the 2021 conservative
campaign team also testified calling on
the Liberals to introduce new foreign
interference legislation but decisions
like that have been left up to the
special rapid Tour on the issue Chris
and David Johnson will also decide if
there should be a public inquiry into
the matter
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thank you
allegations of foreign interference are
very familiar to people in Taiwan the
Taiwanese say they've been targeted for
years by disinformation and interference
campaigns from China and they believe
Canada can learn from their experience
Jeff Semple reports on the creative ways
the self-governed island democracy is
using education and Technology to fight
back against foreign interference
these Taiwanese civilians are receiving
a crash course in surviving a Chinese
military Invasion
the classes teach first aid evacuation
planning and a new addition to the
survival course curriculum debunking
disinformation we're just now beginning
to realize how this information could
cause severe damage the instructors
point to the war in Ukraine where the
Kremlin falsely claims to be rescuing
Russian speakers from Nazis this class
is taught to question similar claims
from Beijing designed to coerce the
Taiwanese to surrender the Chinese
military recently released this
animation of what it says an attack on
Taiwan would look like the CCB
propaganda has have has said they would
use a thousand missiles to to bomb the
entire Island
um and then or something like 50 000
ships storming the shore we explain how
that is impossible well Canada and other
countries have recently been focused on
the threat of foreign interference the
Taiwanese say they've been targeted for
years and have developed novel ways to
fight back here in Taiwan we have been
facing this issue this situation for
decades Freddie Lim's path to politics
began on a different stage
so you were a front man for a heavy
death metal band yeah and now you're a
politician yeah I don't know many of
them and I might be the only one for
three decades Lim led the heavy metal
band cathonic but in 2015 he launched
his own National Party using his
distinct voice to condemn Chinese
government intimidation and interference
most of the people nowadays focus on the
military operations but the Chinese
interference in Taiwan is deeper in the
society Lim accuses Beijing of covertly
supporting Taiwanese politicians
academics and Community groups that want
Taiwan to join China after speaking out
he says his own campaign was targeted
they tried to operate a lot of fake
accounts to attack me his team found
thousands of anonymous online accounts
attacking Lim which were all posting the
same messages simultaneously so Lim sent
screenshots of the posts for further
investigation to an organization called
double Think Lab you will see that
someone had posted a screenshot the
non-profit group is one of several
launched in Taiwan in recent years
dedicated to debunking disinformation
and investigating interference Taiwan is
kind of Ground Zero for Chinese
disinformation this Canadian works as a
researcher for doublethink lab in Taiwan
it's quite striking being here in Taiwan
seeing how Taiwanese Civil Society has
really risen up to address the issue
another group called my gopin runs a
disinformation chat bot where users can
send stories or posts they suspect are
fake to a team of fact Checkers what did
they say this was they recently debunked
this viral Tick Tock video which falsely
claimed former U.S House speaker Nancy
Pelosi was visiting Taiwan with a fleet
of fighter jets and warships the U.S
threatening war with China
we see a lot of content that originates
from mainland China says the founder of
my open many of the posts reinforce a
similar narrative says this Canadian who
monitors Chinese media from Taiwan
trying to portray China very positive
light you know as a stable strong
country and a part of that Oso you know
involves
um preying upon the divisions and
supposed chaos of in other countries
together these Taiwanese non-profit
non-governmental organizations are
pushing back against foreign
interference providing A playbook for
other countries all those uh operations
that they have been doing in Taiwan now
they operate the same thing in Canada in
the United States in Western countries
Jeff sample Global News Taipei
now Taiwan supplies the vast majority of
the world's semiconductors the
electronic chips that power everything
from our cars to our computers so
tomorrow we look at the consequences a
Chinese Invasion could have on the
global economy
to the U.S now where President Joe Biden
is officially announcing his bid for
re-election in 2024. the question we're
facing is whether in the years ahead we
have more freedom or less freedom more
rights are fewer
Biden made his official pitch to
Americans in a three-minute video asking
voters to help him finish the job he
started in his first term although not a
surprise the announcement does raise
some questions over the president's age
and fitness for a second term and sets
the stage for a possible sequel of the
2020 contest between Trump and Biden
nitu garcha reports
President Joe Biden's bid for
re-election framed as a fight against
extremism from Republicans if you know
around the country magnet extremists are
lining up to take on those Bedrock
freedoms advocating for more time to
make good on his promise to restore the
nation's character when I ran for
president four years ago
I said we're in a battle for the soul of
America
it was released by video and said the
president being out and among people the
campaign is very much aware that he's
under very heavy scrutiny for his age
this was exactly how he announced his
2020 bid but his first challenge now may
be rallying more enthusiasm and support
from his own party with polls showing a
majority of Americans think age is a
major factor in why he shouldn't run
again he spent his entire life starting
when he was elected to the Senate at the
age of 29 running for president he's not
going to yield that office unless the
voters send him packing or there's a
health problem
Biden will be 82 in 2024 former
president Donald Trump who turned 77
this year and announced his own
re-election bid last fall is Biden's
likely top Challenger for the
Republicans he preemptively released a
statement Monday claiming he'd win in a
rematch against Biden I have no doubt
that we will together win the election
of 2024 and make America great again
he's going to have lots of trouble in
the next coming year with all the
different indictments in his first
public appearance since announcing his
re-election Biden touted job growth in a
speech to Building Trades union members
he set to run again on the same themes
that boosted his party in the past like
preserving access to abortion that's why
I'm running for reelection but Biden's
bid prominently featuring vice president
Kamala Harris comes as he battles low
approval ratings
nithu Canadians love to watch U.S
politics how are people reacting to
today's announcement
Chris prime minister Justin Drew
interviews when asked by reporters on
Parliament Hill he said Biden is the
type of leader needed not only by the
U.S but by the world the president
visited Ottawa last month when he
addressed Parliament saying the U.S will
have no more reliable Ally than Canada
Chris
in Washington thanks nitu a fragile
72-hour ceasefire in Sudan is offering a
narrow window of opportunity for people
trying to flee the violence there MPS
will hold an emergency debate tonight in
the House of Commons over the deepening
crisis Canada says it's preparing for
airlifts there are also two military
vessels standing by off Sudan's Coast
what we are trying to do as a government
is to assist anyone and everyone who has
requested assistance
Canada is defending its evacuation plan
rejecting suggestions it's falling
behind its allies but critics point out
the slow response is the result of
Decades of under spending on defense
Mike trolley reports
facing intense criticism over its slow
response to the Sudanese crisis Britain
on Tuesday launched a large-scale
evacuation of its trapped citizens with
a 72-hour ceasefire tenuously in place
the race is on to get out of Sudan by
all accounts there are no safe spots
left in hartum but then our house was
hit by a missile
and and the missile didn't go off it
just went through the roof and it's just
we think it's still there in the house
so that became no longer a safe option
we had to move out like Britain Canada
has been criticized for its slow
response the Canadian government reports
it has been in contact with 1700
Canadians in Sudan of those 550 have
requested assistance and 100 have left
the country but none via Canadian
military planes prime minister Justin
Trudeau says Canada has assets in the
region they just can't find anywhere
safe to land there's very limited both
places where those airlifts can happen
from when asked about Canada's
lackluster plan foreign affairs minister
Melanie Jolie says the crisis took them
by surprise as a result Canada has had
to rely on its allies notably Germany
France at the United Arab Emirates and
Saudi Arabia for air support we can't
just land any old plane in this theater
of operations we need the capability
that comes with those assets as well
International Affairs expert Ann
Fitzgerald says Canada's lack of
military Readiness is a result of
Decades of Financial and political
neglect this is not a storm that's going
to go away easily this will arise again
and again and again for now Canadians
looking to leave Sudan are hoping for
another helping hand microlight Global
News Toronto at least two people are
dead and 10 others injured after a
missile strike on a museum in the
Ukrainian city of kupiansk
rescue workers dug through the rubble of
the local History Museum to retrieve the
bodies the Ukrainian government says it
was hit by a Russian missile local
officials stressed there are no military
facilities near the museum and accused
Russia of deliberately hitting civilian
targets to terrorize the local
population Russia has denied targeting
civilians in its full-scale invasion of
Ukraine so long Saddle Dome just ahead
what's replacing Calgary's aging hockey
arena
the Calgary Skyline is about to undergo
a big change the city's reached a deal
for 900 million dollars in Government
funding to replace the Aging Saddle Dome
the arena will anchor the culture and
Entertainment District in the city's
downtown an earlier deal collapsed in
2021 when the Flames walked away over
Rising costs the Saddle Dome was built
in 1983 it's one of the oldest in the
league there is no timeline for
completion
the Canadian astronaut and three
American crewmates who will become the
first to circle the moon in more than 50
years were recognized in the House of
Commons today
Mission specialist Canadian Jeremy
Hansen Commander Reed
Jeremy Hansen and his crewmates were
announced as the Artemis II crew earlier
this month they are scheduled for launch
late next year and while no one will
actually land on the moon during this
mission NASA wants to attempt a
two-person lunar Landing as early as
2025.
trip of a lifetime next the rare
diagnosis inspiring a Canadian family to
go on a world tour
[Music]
a Quebec family is back in Canada after
spending 12 months traveling the globe
the goal was to collect visual memories
because three of the four children have
a rare condition that is slowly robbing
them of their eyesight the diagnosis was
a nightmare but as Mike Armstrong shows
us it led to a dream trip
after a year away unpacking the
suitcases was the easy part unpacking
the house is the Big Challenge we lent
the house to uh to some friends uh so we
packed everything and now we're
unpacking well the Peltier Lemay family
all six of them arrived back in Canada
April 19th back from a year collecting
everywhere they went they went to a lot
of places they were gathering and saving
experiences
the first goal was to fill my kids
visual memory that was a goal just to
show them beautiful things
now the trip was kind of a reaction to
some terrible news in 2018 their
daughter Mia was diagnosed with
retinitis Pigmentosa it's a rare genetic
condition that over time causes
blindness when that diagnosis came in
Edith name and Sebastian knew two of
their sons had the same symptoms we knew
we were hoping it wouldn't turn positive
for them but um deep down we knew
so of course it was devastating
one of the Specialists told the couple
to try to give their children memories
show them pictures and books show them
elephants and giraffes in the zoo well
they decided instead to go as they put
it all in it also wasn't just about
seeing things but having experiences
meeting people and discovering cultures
and really discover different ways of
living
you know over and above the the visual
memories that they got I think they got
a great Human Experience uh all together
Indonesia turkey and Tanzania parents
gave their children the trip of a
lifetime and memories meant to last that
long things to remember when they can't
see
but there was also a lesson passed down
peltsy and Lemay showed their children's
strength and how to face a challenge
head on and together
my karma Stone Global News Montreal
and that is global national for this
Tuesday night I'm Chris Galas tonight's
your candidate is the Adam and Eve rocks
in Buckhorn Ontario thanks very much for
watching Donna Friesen will be back at
the anchor desk tomorrow hope you have a
great evening
[Music]